>>Ben: Everybody who makes something
really, really wonderful gets there
through a process of making something
that's really not that great
to start with, and then slowly
improving it, taking feedback,
getting new ideas, in what I think is
a process that's a little bit closer
to the real world.
>>The decisions that you need
to make today are decisions
about what's gonna get into the game
and what's gonna need to be left out,
in order for you to finish
in time for the fifth graders
to actually play these
games in a week, okay?
>>In this project that
they're working on right now,
is the biggest one of the year.
They're making an educational
video game
for a particular fifth grade
class that we went and visited
at a local elementary school.
>>Oh, oh, it's when the corn pops
up and it's ready to harvest.
Do you have to actually
activate on each one?
>>And so we went and interviewed
the students and got to know them
and found out what kinds
of music they listened to,
what movies they like, the cartoon
characters that they follow,
the video games that
they already play.
Students also interviewed the
fifth grade teacher and found
out what the learning objectives are,
the California State fifth
grade content standards.
And so by going there and really
seeing what their classroom was like,
we were sort of immersed into
their world, and we understand
that we're creating
something for them.
>>Why are we hitting
the out of memory here?
You've hit it.
>>Student: Images.
>>Ben: Because of what?
>>Student: Too many images.
>>Ben: Too many images, or the
images themselves are too big, right?
>>Ben: The software that we
use is called Processing,
and it's actually a project that
was initiated at the MIT Media Lab.
It uses the Java syntax.
The thing that Processing provides
is a built in graphics library
and a really easy sort
of development process,
so you don't have to compile in it.
You just push play, and then
your code immediately turns
into something that's
happening on the screen.
>>Student: It's pretty
interesting to do, I mean like,
if you want to be a computer or a
scientist and it's a good starter.
>>Ben: We form teams and the teams
go through a brainstorming process
and an idea refinement process.
>>Right now, I have teams of three.
The different roles that the students
take on are the technical lead,
and that's the person who's
gonna be sort of most responsible
for the programming, the art lead,
the person who's gonna be responsible
for not only the concept art,
but actually the production are,
the actual, you know, pixels that
go on the screen during the game,
and then a project manager.
>>Student: Half the map's
gonna be like a city.
Other half is gonna be like
a grass playing type of area.
>>Student: I'm the project manager,
which is basically telling these guys
when the project is due, like what
we need to catch up on, the schedule,
what kinda pace we're gonna be on.
>>Ben: Instead of having there
be a designated designer role,
it's actually that
everybody is the designer.
>>Student: I took like an image
of a horse shrinking down.
Then I remade it into
a pixelated horse.
>>Ben: There's thirteen teams
and there's some pretty
interesting stuff going on.
There's a game called Cookie
Attack and it's about fractions.
I think this is a real achievement in
terms of responding to the audience.
>>Student: We noticed that
the fifth graders, they--
this kind of like violence and we
kind of incorporate it into our game,
where they have to answer the
questions to get the cookies
and they have to use the
cookies to shoot the monsters.
>>Student: I'm better at
programming than all the other stuff,
so I did the programming
and then Miranda,
she's better at Photoshop,
so she did the graphics.
And then Angel, her part was to
separate kind of like the jobs
and then find some concepts.
>>Ben: Just recently, actually,
that fifth grade class came here
to Galileo and visited us, and we
had a chance to show them some demos
and some prototypes of the games
that my students are working on.
And my students took that feedback to
really help them shape their games.
>>Student: Was this
in the same thing?
>>Student: No, this is
screen number three.
This one, you exit in.
>>Student: No, no, oh.
>>Student: I really wanna know
if they get bored of the game
or if they're having fun with it,
because it makes me feel happy
if they like the game, but if
they have some bad feedback,
then I'd have to work on
it some more, you know.
>>Ben: By doing a project
that has a real audience,
I think it provides a little bit more
motivation to really put the effort
into making it good and that
allows them an opportunity to find
out that you don't just make
something good the first time
you try.
And software that's
running on computers,
whether it's on your Smartphone
or on your desktop computer,
or on a website somewhere,
that software dominates
a lot of our reality.
So having some idea of how those
things work, I think allows you
to be just a more informed citizen.